votre votre parti parti pirate quand on
vous dit on va stocker des données
sanitaires et puis ça sera plus ou moins
obligatoire de présenter un test pcr
négatif ou ou un certificat de
vaccination un certificat du fait que
vous avez déjà attrapé le coville et
c'est donc il ya un côté très
obligatoire est ce que ce n'est pas un
peu liberticide selon vous bon il est
vrai que tout le monde espère que les
restrictions de la libre circulation et
d'autres droits fondamentaux seront
élevés et donc pour cette raison les
certificats européens ont envisagé sans
une bonne solution en général mais la
proposition spécifique
la commission est insuffisante en
matière de protection de données et de
non discrimination parce que par exemple
il n'est pas et n'a pas de garantie que
la variante numérique du certificat soit
stocké de mathier de manière
décentralisée sur les appareils de la
personne concernée et non dans un
registre de vaccination centrale et de
plus les citoyens n'ont pas le choix de
recevoir un certificat soit sur papier
soit numérique sauf si leur état membre
de leur accorde et c'est un problème
pour les personnes qui n'ont pas de
smartphone par exemple
oui mais patrick brière se passe
justement ces certificats verts c'est
pour éviter notamment les fraudes un les
fausses attestations de test voilà donc
peut-être que ça ça permet aussi
d'éviter les fraudes qui se multiplient
oui c'est vrai que les certificats
européens sont une bonne idée pour les
utiliser aussi dans d'autres pays
à ce temps là il ya des problèmes si
vous présenter un certificat dans une
autre langue par exemple et donc c'est
une bonne idée mais la proposition de
règlement spécifique toujours permet de
lier la liberté de voyage à la
vaccination et ne pas
accepter les tests négatifs comme
alternative et ce qui constitue une
discrimination et donc il faudra ont
travaillé et l'améliorer
[Musique]